hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
I've got something very special for you
my longest ever video and in this video
we'll be discussing what happened to 100
that's right 100 different characters
from Harry Potter after the story had
ended after the battle of Hogwarts and
the closing of the Deathly Hallows we
barely got a glimpse of what happened in
the lives of the characters we grew to
love and in some instances hate so much
but fortunately thanks to Extended lore
and a lot of research on my part I've
got some answers for you guys this is
already a long video so I won't waste
any more time let's dive into it
Voldemort I know what you're thinking
didn't Voldemort die well technically
yes his physical form was destroyed but
that certainly doesn't mean that
Voldemort met his true end you see
because of the cursed lives that
Voldemort chose he was sent to a place
that is neither representative of life
nor death Voldemort had sacrificed his
soul on countless occasions doing
anything and everything he could to
achieve his goal of immortality during
his lifetime Voldemort committed
atrocity after atrocity murdering people
to create horcruxes and even killing and
drinking the blood of a unicorn an act
so vile that the Drinker is destined to
have a cursed existence so you see
Voldemort's Soul could never have been
at rest and for the life that he chose
to live he had to pay the ultimate price
an existence in limbo limbo is often
perceived as a forgotten or ignored
place a place that interestingly enough
would have been a stark reminder of
Voldemort's formative years when he was
left at Wars orphanage as a baby
Neville Longbottom after the battle of
Hogwarts Neville didn't waste any time
in pursuing a career as an aura and
gifted Aura he was however it later
become clear that being an aura wasn't
his true passion and when he was offered
a position at Hogwarts by now
headmistress minerv McGonagall he
accepted you see Neville was also
particularly passionate about one
subject while at school herbology and it
just so happened that his new role would
have him working under herbology
department head Pomona Sprouts Neville
would eventually go on to marry former
classmate Hannah Abbott a Hufflepuff
student and former member of
Dumbledore's Army because Hannah worked
as a landlady for leaky cauldron it was
only natural that Neville and Hannah
would live upstairs but they lived for
many years after some time Hannah
eventually applied for the job of matron
and Hogwarts
Ron Weasley the epilogue certainly gave
away aspects of Ron's feature
particularly as he is shown sending his
children off to Hogwarts a platform nine
and three quarters alongside his new
wife Hermione Granger the pair had two
children Rose and Hugo Granger Weasley
in the epilogue Ron and Hermione can be
seen sending Rose off to Hogwarts along
with Harry's son Albus in addition to
marrying Hermione Ron pursued the career
path of an aura and eventually became an
aura for the ministry of magic JK
Rowling had this to say of Ron joining
the ministry
Harry and Ron utterly revolutionized the
aura Department Rowling said they are
now the experts it doesn't matter how
old they are or what else they've done
rolling also emphasized that by joining
the ministry Harry and Ron helped
revolutionize it into a really good
place to be they made a new world
Rowling said however Ron didn't remain
at the ministry forever and later left
so that he could help out his brother
George Weasley with the Weasley's
Wizarding wheezers at joke shop it has
also been expressed that despite Ron's
terrible driving track record he did
eventually obtain a Michael driving
license even if he had to place a
confundus charm on the driving
instructor to get it
Hermione Granger the first thing
Hermione did after the battle of
Hogwarts was find her parents if you
don't remember Hermione had to make a
difficult Choice during the war with
Voldemort in which she wiped their
memories and convinced them to relocate
to Australia this was all in the effort
of protecting them but it was a somber
moment for sure fortunately with
Voldemort out of the way this gave her
an opportunity to track them down and
restored memories that she had
previously wiped after this in typical
Hermione fashion she ended up going back
to Hogwarts in order to attain her nudes
after this she began her post-hogwarts
career at the department for the
regulation and control of magical
creatures where she was able to help
improve the lives of house elves and
alike after some time in the position
she eventually moved to the Department
of magical law enforcement where she was
instrumental in helping to abolish Pro
pure blood laws oh yeah and during all
of this Hermione and Ron Weasley became
a proper item going on to get married
and have two children and as if Hermione
hadn't done enough in her post Hogwarts
years it's been expressed that in 2019
she even became a minister for magic
Hermione's life posted the Hallows
certainly wasn't short of excitement
Harry Potter and the epilogue of the
final installment we learned that Harry
ended up marrying shocker Ginny Weasley
and that they had two sons James Sirius
and Alpha Severus as well as a daughter
Lily Luna and like Hermione Harry never
returned to Hogwarts to finish his nudes
but he did Dive Right into his career as
an aura at the ministry of magic as it
turns out Harry was able to achieve the
honor of head Aura at the ripe age of
26. it's also been revealed that in
addition to raising his own kids Harry
spent a considerable amount of time with
Teddy Lupine the orphaned son of Remus
and Tonks Teddy was officially raised by
his grandmother but Harry helped
whenever he could Harry Ron and Hermione
were also eventually immortalized on
chocolate frog cards for their
contributions to Wizarding Society
George Weasley what happened to George
can best be summarized by Rolling
herself a lot of readers asked me was
George all right and of course he
wouldn't be all right would he that's
the reality but I think that he married
Angelina who was actually Fred's ex
maybe it's a bit unhealthy but I think
they would have been happy as happy as
he could be without Fred I think he
really would have felt like part of
himself died I don't think that George
would ever get over losing Fred which
makes me feel so sad however he names
his first child and Son Fred and he goes
on to have a very successful career
helped by good old Ron Ron joined George
at Weasley's Wizarding wheezes which
became an enormous money spinner
Luna Lovegood it turns out that later in
life Luna went on to become a rather
famous magic zoologist for those
unfamiliar with the profession magic
zoologist is a wizard or wedge who
studies magical creatures this
profession shouldn't come as a surprise
given that Luna exhibited an affinity
for magical creatures during the Harry
Potter story properly introducing Harry
to thestrals in the Order of the Phoenix
the perhaps most notable magic zoologist
is newt's commander who wrote Fantastic
Beasts and Where to Find Them
interestingly enough Luna actually went
on to marry wolves Commander newt's
grandson it has been expressed that for
their wedding Luna dressed in typical
eccentric lunar fashion sporting a
rainbow dress and tiara with unicorn
horns later on sometime between the
years 2008 and 2014 the pep had two sons
Larkin and lykender as an adult Luna
remained close friends with Harry Ron
and Hermione in fact Luna made such an
impression on Harry that he named his
daughter Lily Luna after his mother and
of course Luna a true honor according to
Rowling Luna never changed she remained
a quirky lovable self which is what I
think we all hoped for
Hagrid it turns out that Hagrid simply
continued working at Hogwarts in his
usual posting the only thing at Hagrid
love modern Hogwarts was his love of
magical creatures which explains why he
would choose to continue on as Professor
for the care of magical creatures at the
school Hagrid is also referenced in the
epilogue by Harry while speaking to his
son Albus bye Al said Harry Met his son
hugged him don't forget Hagrid's invited
you to tea next Friday don't mess with
peeves don't Jewel anyone till you've
learned how and don't let James wind you
up the epilogue of Harry Potter gave us
a glimpse of 19 years into the future
which would make the year 2017 and
Hagrid 89 years old however thanks to
the longevity of wizard kind I'm sure
that Hagrid was still very sprightly in
addition to teaching at Hogwarts it's
been suggested that Hagrid may have at
one point further pursued a relationship
with Madame Maxime however the two
eventually proved to be too different to
make things work
Draco Malfoy as it turns out draco's
post hoggles life and well overall
demeanor has been written about
extensively on Pottermore it's also a
bit somber the biggest Revelation was
that he became less of a pureblood
fanatic the events of draco's late teens
forever changed his life he had had the
beliefs with which he had grown up
challenged in the most frightening way
he'd experienced Terror and despair
seeing his parents suffer for their
allegiance and had witnessed the
crumbling of all that his family had
believed in after the events of the
second Wizarding War Lucius found his
son as affectionate as ever but refusing
to follow the same old pure bloodline
Draco married the younger sister the
fellow Southern Astoria Greengrass who
had gone to race similar though less
violent and frightening conversion from
pure blood ideals to a more tolerant
Life View was felt by Narcissa and
Lucius to be something of a
disappointment as a daughter-in-law as
Astoria refused to raise their grandson
Scorpius in the belief that Muggles were
scum found Gatherings are often fraught
with tension also he seemingly mellowed
out a bit leading a life of leisure
instead of working to overturn the
forces of light or establish Dominion of
a Muggles like Lucius did I imagine that
Draco grew up to lead a modified version
of his father's existence independently
wealthy without any need to work Draco
inhabits Malfoy Manor with his wife and
son as mentioned above the pair had a
child Scorpius Malfoy who attended
Hogwarts at the same time as Albus
Severus Potter in a tragic turn of
events Astoria actually ended up dying
quite young falling victim to a
bloodborne family curse this left Draco
a single father who lived out his days
mostly alone
the dursleys interestingly enough very
little is revealed about the dursleys
after they pack up and head off however
it turns out the Dudley's moment of
redemption the deleted scene where he
shakes Harry's hand may have had quite
an impact on their relationship in fact
it is later revealed by Rolling that
despite deadly's years of abuse towards
Harry they were later on Christmas card
terms as he Grew Older Dudley developed
into a decent man very much unlike the
tyrannous force of nature that he
embodied in his youth Dudley even
eventually got married and had a family
of his own raising two muggled children
Harry and Dudley would still see each
other enough to be on Christmas card
terms but they would visit more out of a
sense of Duty and sit in silence so that
their children could see their cousins
this suggests that they were never quite
friends but certainly cordial to one
another perhaps stemming from the mutual
respect that they gained for one another
later in life as for Vernon and petunia
it seems as though Harry may not have
seen them again as their relationship
was never particularly good though
petunia certainly harbored affection for
Harry deep within she never made the
same attempt that Dudley made to
reconcile with him which was likely the
reason for them never reconnecting it's
also been suggested that after the fall
of Voldemort the jerseys were simply
escorted back to their home in little
whinging where they remained for the
rest of their lives
umbrage Umbridge is arguably the worst
character in the entire Harry Potter
story and she first makes her Mark when
she infiltrates Hogwarts and makes life
at the school a living hell probably an
understatement that is until she's
tricked into traveling to the Forbidden
Forest by Harry and Hermione only to be
met with the horde of angry centaurs who
carry her off after this she's saved by
Dumbledore and sacked from her
headmistress position after it's
revealed that Voldemort had in fact
returned amazingly however Umbridge
still found herself with a job after
leaving Hogwarts in fact the ministry
accepted her back in her previous role
of senior under secretary to the
minister of magic also at this stage the
ministry had a new Minister Rufus
scrimger despite a brief appearance at
Dumbledore's funeral the next we hear of
Ambridge is in 1997 following
Voldemort's takeover of the ministry in
addition to her primary position of
under secretary
Umbridge also became head of the among
born registration commission but she
conducted trials that were effectively
designed to prosecute mugglebones
Umbridge doesn't appear much more in the
story after this as there are bigger
problems in the Wizarding World Lord
Voldemort however with Voldemort's
eventual downfall the ministry once
again came under the control of normal
witches and wizards expunging all of
Voldemort's followers from positions of
power the ministry of magic essentially
underwent a Reformation led by a new
Minister for magic fully aware of the
type of person that Umbridge was and the
crimes that she'd committed during
Voldemort's regime the new Minister had
Umbridge rested tried convicted and
given a life sentence to the island
Fortress of Azkaban where she lived out
her days
Cornelius fudge Cornelius fudge order of
Merlin first class self-appointed was
the 32nd Minister for magic serving from
1990 to 1996 spanning most of the years
Harry attended Hogwarts a fudge
exhibited some very questionable
behavior during his time in office the
most questionable being his persistent
denial of Voldemort's return which in
turn caused fudge to meddle in all kinds
of Affairs in The Wizarding World
including the management of Hogwarts
School when it was eventually proven
that Voldemort had in fact returned it
cost fudge's job and Rufus grimga took
over his position at this stage however
fudge wasn't out of the ministry
entirely as he was kept on in an
advisory capacity communicating news of
the second Wizarding War to the Mughal
prime minister if scrimger was unable to
When The War eventually ended fudge was
relieved of this position as well fudges
fate is exactly what can be expected
when a foolish and ineffectual person is
given too much power in the end fudge
was scorned by the public and unemployed
quietly living the rest of his shameful
existence out of the spotlight take the
steps I've suggested and you will be
remembered in office or out as one of
the bravest and greatest ministers for
magic we have ever known fail to act and
history will remember you as the man who
stepped aside and allowed Voldemort a
second chance to destroy the world we
have tried to rebuild Alba stumbledore
Lockhart in the Chamber of Secrets
Lockhart is forced by the boys to come
down into the chamber with them and this
is where things really went South for
him hoping to take control of the
situation Lockhart grabbed Ron's broken
wand and attempted to perform a memory
charm on them the adventure ends here
boys I shall take a bit of this skin
back up to the school tell them I was
too late to save the girl and that you
two tragically lost your mind at the
sight of a mangled body say goodbye to
your memories obliviate however given
that the wand was well broken it
backfired on Lockhart instead the faulty
wand sent him flying into a pile of
rubble and subsequently caused him to
lose all of his memories complete
Amnesia who was no longer the brave
troll conqueror and dragon tamer in fact
he didn't know who he was Lockhart is
later saved by forks and brought to
mcgonagall's office at which point it
became apparent to staff and students
alike that Lockhart had completely lost
his marbles with Dumbledore instructing
Ron to take him to to the hospital Wing
after careful inspection it was decided
that Lockhart wouldn't be able to
operate in society in the state that he
was in and he was subsequently sent to
the Janus Thicke ward in Saint mungo's
Hospital for Magical maladies a war
dedicated to those suffering from
permanent spell damage during Christmas
in 1995 Harry Ron Hermione and Ginny saw
Lockhart in the jaina sticky Ward and
despite the total loss of his memory he
seemed just as Lockhart as ever offering
up autographs and the like he'd regained
just enough memory to remember writing
in cursive and teach me did I taught you
everything you know I expect did I well
how about those autographs then shall we
say a round dozen you can give them to
your little friends then and nobody will
be left out sadly Lockhart never got to
many visitors but he's still got fan
mail from a witch named Gladys gojin and
developed a close relationship with his
carer Miriam Strauss though Lockhart
never made a full recovery he did to
sign autographs for the rest of his days
and it has been expressed the dude was
happier that way blissfully ignorant but
more than happy to reap the benefits of
his illustrious Fame to this day no one
knows if he ever properly left saint
mungo's
philia splitwick Flitwick Hogwarts
resident charms expert and dueling
Champion was largely responsible for
casting many of the most effective
defensive enchantments surrounding
Hogwarts during the great battle at the
end of the second Wizarding War these
defenses kept the Death Eaters at Bay
for a considerable amount of time and if
it weren't for his charms expertise then
the battle may have gone very
differently as it allowed the good guys
to get better prepared Flitwick is
thought to be one of the most talented
charms teachers to ever teach at
Hogwarts and following the Battle
Flitwick continued his tenure as charms
Master diligently educating the next
Generations of witches and wizards on
the topic
filge Marcus filch Squibb went on to
assume the role of Hogwarts caretaker
succeedingly previous caretaker Napoleon
Pringle in 1968. throughout the books
and films filch gives the trio among
many others their fair share of grief
but when the Battle of Hogwarts came
vilch was quick to oversee the safe
evacuation of most of the school
students he may have been foul-tempered
in bitter but filch took his job
seriously which is why you won't be
surprised to hear that he continued on
in his position of caretaker after the
war had ended immediately after the
battle vilch was seen sweeping near the
Great Hall filch is likely still
punishing students and arguing with
peeves to this day
Ollivander Ollivander first name Garrick
operated olivender's one shop in Diagon
Alley one of Harry's first stops before
beginning his first year at Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry
Ollivander revolutionized the way that
one making was approached and before he
took over his father's one shop it was
common for wizards to use a broad
variety of wand cause during the second
Wizarding War Ollivander was tortured
perhaps more than anyone else this is
due to ollivander's knowledge of ones
and Voldemort's obsession with the Elder
Wand after recovering at Shell cottage
for some time olivander traveled to
Muriel's house where he remained until
the end of the war fortunately
Ollivander ended up making a full
recovery and returned to work at his one
shop shortly after Voldemort had been
defeated serving future witches and
wizards for decades to come
Kingsley shackle bolt Kingsley shackle
bolt was a British pure blood wizard
Order of the Phoenix member powerful
Aura and later Minister for magic
Kingsley was a later addition to the
order and joined during the second
Wizarding War Kingsley was an immense
help against Voldemort and the Death
Eaters during The Wizarding war and
after helping to oversee the capture and
containment of Death Eaters and
Voldemort supporters after Voldemort's
defeat when the dust had finally settled
he was properly appointed as the 35th
official Minister for magic he was
previously just to caretaker minister in
this role among other acts Kingsley
helped to rid the ministry of corruption
banned Dementors from guarding Azkaban
appointed Harry as head of the aura
department and along with Hermione
eradicated Pro pureblood views
Pomona Sprouts Pomona Sprout was a
British witch that taught it to Hogwarts
for many years she served as both the
head of Hufflepuff house as well as the
head of the herbology department Pomona
proved to be instrumental in helping the
good guys fight off the Death Eaters
during the Battle of Hogwarts tentacular
devil snare and snuggle of PODS yes I'd
like to see the Death Eaters fighting
those after the war Sprout remained a
teaching at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry as herbology
professor and when 2008 rolled around
she was joined in the department by
former pupil Neville Longbottom who
talked alongside her
Arthur Molly Weasley let's start with
Molly Molly to Rogue actions during the
second Wizarding War earned her quite
the reputation she became quite well
known as the witch that defeated and
killed The Notorious Death Eater
Bellatrix Lestrange Arthur continued
working with the ministry of magic and
fought to improve Mughal rights with the
help of Kingsley shackle bolt other than
that Molly and Arthur lived out the rest
of their days quietly and joined the
company of their dozen grandchildren
Percy Weasley though Percy had drawn
down a rather dubious path for most of
the books and films he did eventually
make up with his family during the
Battle of Hogwarts Percy survived a
battle but like the rest of his family
was significantly affected by the death
of his brother Fred after the war Percy
returned to work for the ministry as a
high-ranking official under the new
Minister for magic King's Lee
shacklebolt he married a woman named
Audrey and had two daughters Molly and
Lucy Molly was of course named after his
mother
aberforth Abba fourth Dumbledore was a
British Half Blood wizard the older
brother of Ariana Dumbledore the younger
brother of Hogwarts Headmaster Albus
Dumbledore and the son of Kendra and
Percival Dumbledore amberforth had a
poor relationship with his brother as
they were both involved in a three-way
Jewel involving Grindelwald that led to
the death of their sister Ariana when
Ariana died it basically ended their
relationship as aberforth blamed Albus
for her death even though Albus and Abba
fought were brothers and fairly close in
age they were always very different
aberforth is presented by Rowling in a
bit of an interesting light perhaps you
provide a bit of comic relief as in the
Goblet of Fire it's mentioned briefly
that abbaford has a bit of an unusual
relationship with his goats in fact he
was even prosecuted for the supposed
things that he did with goats what he
did with goats has never actually been
disclosed but what we do know about this
odd natured Wizard and this shouldn't
surprise you is that after the war he
kept a low profile living about the rest
of his days tending to his goats of
course aberforth also resumed his role
as the barman at the Hogs Head Inn where
he served butterbeer to the Future
generations of Hogwarts students for
decades to come no one knows if Abba
fourth ever truly forgave his brother
Albus for his role in the entirely
avoidable Jewel that resulted in his
sister's death but I certainly like to
think so
Fleur de la core Fleur Isabel de la core
later Fleur Weasley was a French Quarter
Villa witch born in the year 1977. Fleur
is first introduced in the goblet of
fire under the context of the Triumph
was a tournament and emphasis was placed
on her because she was the champion
representing her school bobato shortly
after the event of the trial was a
tournament in the summer of 1995 Fleur
took on a role at Gringotts in order to
improve her English it was here that she
met one of the older Weasley children
Bill who was working there as a curse
breaker the two hit it off straight away
and nearly immediately began dating with
Bill eventually proposing the pair get
married in the story but it seems to
occur just as The Wizarding World is
collapsing so my question is given that
the two of them survived the war what
happened next well it should come as no
surprise that bill and Fleur after
getting married went on to her children
of their own Fleur became the mother of
three children
Louis and Dominique Weasley expanding
the already prolific Weasley Clan even
more given that both Victor and
Dominique were female and that Fleur had
Villa blood in her veins her daughters
also possessed Villa blood this made
them 1 8th Villa technically Louis had
the same blood in him but it has been
reinforced through Canon that Villas are
only women though Bill survived the war
and his severe injuries inflicted by the
notorious werewolf fenrir greybach
specifically avoiding becoming a
werewolf himself it has been expressed
that he did develop the tendency to
enjoy very rare steaks
Sheamus Finnegan Sheamus Finnegan was an
Irish half-bud wizard born in the Year
1980 whose father was a muggle and whose
mam was a witch Sheamus was a fellow
Gryffindor sharing a common room with
the likes of the trio and as a secondary
character in the series pops up every
once in a while throughout the entire
story starting as early as the first
book Sheamus helped his best he could
during the Battle of Hogwarts
unfortunately he was able to survive the
war immediately after the battle had
ended he could be seen sitting with Dean
Thomas and Amber for Dumbledore while
this hasn't been confirmed through Canon
I like to imagine that Sheamus ended up
working in some kind of role pertaining
to pyrotechnics the young Irishman had a
knack for blowing things up after all
perhaps a career in magical fireworks
McGonagall Minerva McGonagall was a
Scottish half-bud witch born in 1935 two
parents Robert McGonagall and Isabel
Ross after a chaotic first few Decades
of her life involving familial issues
and heartbreak she eventually found
herself working at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry the same school
that she herself attended in her youth
we know McGonagall as the stern but kind
Transfiguration Professor that was
always quick to call out Harry and Ron
for being late but was also the first
person to be standing in front of and
defending her students if something went
awry mcgonagall's loyalty to Hogwarts
eventually earned her the title of
headmistress after Dumbledore had died
and Snape had been ousted from the
school McGonagall played a pivotal role
in the defense of Hogwarts school during
the final battle and luckily she
survived after the war ended she was
awarded the order of Merlin by Minister
for magic Kingsley shacklebolt due to
her loyalty to the Order of the Phoenix
once the school overcame the destruction
McGonagall returned to her position as
headmistress of Hogwarts and stayed in
the role until at least the
2021-22 school year whether she's still
there or not remains unclear
Narcissa Lucius Lucius Malfoy and
Narcissa Malfoy born Narcissa black
where the prejudiced pure blood
extremist parents of secondary and
sometimes primary antagonist Draco
Malfoy Harry's Pier Lucius despite his
commitment to the dark lord was known to
be a bit of a sniveling coward which
meant that similar to Pettigrew he
showed loyalty to wherever he believed
the power was after the battle of
Hogwarts had ended Voldemort was dead
which meant that they no longer had the
security blanket that came with any kind
of Association to him this left their
fate entirely up to the good guys the
rest of the Wizarding World when it
started to look like Voldemort's regime
was about to fall the Malfoy family
simply hung their heads and walked away
from the Hogwarts grounds in shame so
what came of them were they given life
imprisonment in Azkaban or were they
forced to endure some other equally
awful fate it would appear that after
the event of the Deathly Hallows Lucius
and his family managed to avoid
sentencing by revealing information
names Etc about the surviving Death
Eaters ensuring that the Wizarding World
could move forward in perfect harmony
with no more spikes in evil meant that
capturing the remaining Death Eaters was
of utmost importance therefore when
Lucius willfully offered to reveal this
information in exchange for him and his
family's Freedom the ministry of magic
which was in tatters at that point was
more than willing to take him up on it
after being pardoned it seems as though
they kept a relatively low profile
despite no longer being openly evil they
certainly still held on to a lot of the
same beliefs that they always held and
weren't any more tolerant of Muggles or
half-bloods the pair also remained
critical of Draco and his wife for
raising their grandson Scorpius with
their more tolerant world view
comic mclagan Cormac mclagan was a
British pure blood wizard born in 1979
who was probably best known for his
pompous attitude mclagan was a fellow
Gryffindor just one year above Harry and
was also a member of slughorn's slug
club like most gryffindors McLaughlin II
participated in the final battle of the
second Wizarding War fighting alongside
the Defenders of Hogwarts mclagan
survived the final battle and no one
really knows what happened to him after
the war despite mclagan's arrogance
throughout most of the story we do have
to give him credit for the role that he
played in the final battle acting as a
leader and showing immense bravery maybe
mclagan didn't turn out so bad after all
group grew up a small giant bit of
noxymoron there and Hagrid's
half-brother is first introduced to us
when Hagrid brings the trio to the
Forbidden Forest to make introductions
Hagrid discovered his brother grew up
while making a trip to the tribe of
giants in 1995 on Albus Dumbledore's
orders the first thing I want to address
is that group did in fact survive the
Battle of Hogwarts and immediately after
their Victory could be seen celebrating
and laughing while students threw food
into his mouth other than not being
listed as a casualty in the battle
there's no definitive Canon answer as to
what happened to grope but I do have a
fairly conservative Theory you see after
unbridgements acted Hogwarts Dumbledore
and Hagrid thought it would be best to
send group to live in a cave in the
mountains near hogsmead as it turns out
group enjoyed the cave quite a lot and
much preferred it to the forest where he
lived previously though grope emerged
from his Mountain cave to fight in the
battle of Hogwarts I think that the cave
was actually a great home the group that
he simply returned to live there after
the battle by this Stage Group had
developed considerably from when Hagrid
first found him and even began to show
an understanding of human emotions like
happiness and joy given that Hagrid
stayed on as gameskeeper I think that
grope would have simply lived out his
days traveling between Hogwarts School
and the mountains near hogsmeade
Rita Skeeter British witch Rita Skeeter
the extremely conniving journalist built
her Infamous reputation around writing
defamation pieces full of misinformation
for the daily Prophet no one was safe
from her poison pieces even Alba
Dumbledore who once remarked that
Skeeter was enchantingly nasty we don't
have to guess what happened to Skeeter
because it's been well touched on by
Rolling In interviews naturally what
could stop Rita from still reporting
imagine she immediately dashed off a
biography of Harry after he defeated
Voldemort one quarter truth to
three-quarters rubbish it has been
revealed that she also wrote biography
Hatchet jobs on both Severus Snape and
newt's Commander these pieces were
titled Snape scoundrel or Saint and Mano
monster the truth about newt's Commander
respectively essentially Rita lived out
her days being Rita continuing to live
and work as a successful reporter and
author
Slughorn Horus Slughorn is a British
wizard with a long history at Hogwarts
he was head of Slytherin house resident
potions master and even the official
host of slug Club slughghorn infamously
told Tom Riddle about horcruxes as
glaucom's fear of Dumbledore finding out
led to his initial retirement from the
post however slokhorn later returned to
the school after a long Hiatus
continuing on as potions Master Slughorn
played an important role in a Wizarding
War fighting valiantly in the final
battle alongside his students and peers
fortunately slaghorn was able to survive
and continued working at Hogwarts acting
as head of Southern and overseeing the
first year sorting ceremony sometime
before 2016 slycorn fully retired and he
received the honor of having a portrait
of himself placed in the Slytherin
common room
Dean Thomas Dean Thomas was an English
Half Blood wizard born in the Year 1980
the son of a wizard and a muggle mother
Dean was notably in the same year as
Harry Potter and was also a Gryffindor
student Dean pops up quite a lot in the
Harry Potter story and it should come as
no surprise that he fought valiantly
alongside his allies in the Battle of
Hogwarts a battle that fortunately he
was able to survive
so what came of Dean after the battle
well immediately after Dean was seen
sitting next to Sheamus Finnegan and
aberforth Dumbledore in the Great Hall
beyond that well Canon doesn't give us
any info if I had to guess Dean pursued
a career as an artist I say this because
throughout the story he demonstrates an
affinity for art and he was said to be
quite good with the quill
Charlie Weasley though Charlie didn't
make an appearance in the films he was
certainly present for the Battle of
Hogwarts and survived the battle Charlie
never married nor had children but got
to spend his time with his copious
siblings nieces and nephews being an
outdoorsy type with an affinity for
Dragons Charlie was more preoccupied
with his craft rather than pursuing
ladies apparently in the summer of 2014
nosy journalist Rita Skeeter began to
question his prolonged celibacy
something that was obviously none of her
business
divination Professor fought valiantly in
the Battle of Hogwarts bravely
protecting her friends home and
livelihood and with a move like a tennis
serve she heaved another enormous
Crystal spear from her bag waved her
wand through the air and caused the ball
to speed across the hall and smash
through a window fortunately troll only
survived the battle and afterwards
continued to teach well into the 2010s
continuing her tradition of predicting
the deaths of her students in the year
2020 trelawny published a book entitled
my eyes and how to see past them a book
that Hermione Granger kept on her
shelves in our office at the ministry of
magic
Firenze forenze was a centaur and part
of the Centaur colony located in the
Forbidden Forest vorenze was also the
same Centaur that saved Harry in the
Philosopher's Stone Firenze notably
replaced triloni as divination Professor
after she was sacked by Umbridge though
trelawny was eventually given her
position back at the school Firenze
stayed on and the pair co-taught the
subject
Firenze was active in fighting back
against the Death Eaters during the
second Wizarding war and eventually
sustained serious injuries shaking and
unable to stand by himself Firenze was
laid on raised platform in the Great
Hall during the second half of the
battle fortunately Firenze was able to
survive his injuries a special thanks to
Madame Pomfrey for that after the battle
had ended Firenze was welcomed back into
his Centaur colony where they were
finally forced to acknowledge that
forenses pro-human leanings were not
shameful but honorable Firenze continued
to live out his days teaching divination
alongside trelawny
Oliver wood Oliver wood attended
Hogwarts from 1987 to 1994 and he is
most well known for his passion
surrounding the game of quidditch during
his time at the school wood was both
keeper and captain of the Gryffindor
Quidditch team and was known for his
determination and skill on the field
wood graduated from Hogwarts before
Harry and many of the other main
characters in the story and went on to
join a professional Quidditch team
puddlemere United where he began as a
reserve keeper however wood did
eventually return to Hogwarts in 1998 in
order to offer his support in the fight
against Voldemort and the Death Eaters
wood fought valiantly and also helped to
drag the bodies of the deceased into the
Great Hall fortunately wood did survive
the battle and spent the rest of his
days playing professional quidditch his
true calling
Madame Maxime Madame olymp Maxime was a
French witch and headmistress of bobato
Academy of magic she was 11 feet 6
inches tall and a half giant just like
Hagrid apart from being enormous and the
headmistress of bobato she is perhaps
best well known for her relationship
with Hagrid apart from the book's
initial signifiers that the pair were
possibly romantically linked the
relationship isn't touched on much and
eventually the Goblet of Fire simply
ends with Maxime departing and heading
back to bobato alone their stuffed fans
with one big question what happened with
Hagrid and Maxime rolling once addressed
Hagrid's love life in an interview did
Hagrid ever get married and have
children oh did Hagrid ever get married
and have children no realistically
Hagrid's pool of potential girlfriends
is extremely limited because with the
Giants killing each other off the number
of giantesses around his infinitesimal
and he met one of the only ones and
afraid she thought he was kind of cute
but she was a little more how should I
put it sophisticated than Hagrid so no
bless him it turned out that Maxime
simply thought she was too good for
Hagrid it's certainly a shame that
Maxime was the one that got away but on
the other hand I think that he was
probably the one that was too good for
her we don't know much else about
Maxim's later life but we do know that
she continued on as headmistress of
bobaton
Bill Weasley Bill Weasley was the first
and eldest Weasley child though Bill
survived the war and the copious battles
that transpired he was at one point
severely injured by the notorious
werewolf fenrir greyback fortunately he
avoided turning into a werewolf but it
has been expressed that he did develop
the tendency to enjoy very rare Stakes
following the war bill and his wife
Fleur who he married in 1997 had three
children Victor Dominique and Louis
Weasley
pansy Parkinson pansy Parkinson was a
Slytherin witch in Harry Potter's year
at Hogwarts the Parkinson family were
purebloods and members of the Sacred 28
a list of 28 pure blood Wizarding
families during her time at the school
pansy was both a prefect and a member of
the inquisitorial Squad during the final
battle of the second Wizarding War pansy
infamously spoke up in favor of turning
Harry Potter over to Lord Voldemort her
words however were not well received by
most of her classmates who drew their
ones upon her in Harry's defense little
is known of what happened to Pansy after
the second Wizarding war or her later
life but we do know that she fell out of
touch with Draco JK Rowling said in an
interview that pansy didn't end up
marrying Draco because she always hated
her I loathed panzy Parkinson I don't
love Draco but I really dislike her
she's every girl who ever teased me at
school she's the anti-humanian I loathe
her
Aunt Marge Marge desley was an English
muggle and Vernon dursley's older sister
Marge was an extremely unpleasant woman
and you may remember one particular
visit to the Jersey residence in which
Harry could tolerate no more after
speaking ill of Harry's parents Harry's
magical abilities unintentionally
erupted in the form of a non-verbal
inflating charm which resulted in
March's body inflating this caused her
to float upwards towards the ceiling
Marge was later punctured and had her
memory Modified by The Accidental magic
reversal Squad from the ministry of
magic after this incident the dursleys
never invited Marge to stay again and
Harry never saw her again
Patel twins Padma Parvati both Padma and
Parvati were active in the Battle of
Hogwarts and neither of them had been
listed among the Fallen 50. 50 unknown
casualties in the fight against Lord
Voldemort and his Death Eaters because
of this we're over certain that they
survived a battle there's very little
information available about their later
lives but we do know that both kept
their Dumbledore's Army coins and likely
attended the 2014 reunion of
Dumbledore's Army
Ginny Weasley it probably shouldn't come
as a surprise to anyone that Ginny ended
up marrying the one and only Harry
Potter she was in love with him for
years and though the films didn't do a
very good job of portraying this
relationship they were meant to be the
epilogue of the film gives us just a
glimpse of the lady the Ginny would
become where she is seen sending off her
children to Hogwarts at platform nine
and three-quarters Harry and Ginny had
three children James Albus and Lily
immediately after graduating from
Hogwarts however it has been reported
that Jenny actually became a
professional quidditch player going on
to play for the holyhead harpies in the
years that followed the Harry Potter
series Rowling provided other clues
about Ginny's later life after retiring
to become a mother Ginny joined on with
the daily prophet and became their
official quidditch correspondent this
position eventually matured and she
became the sports editor for the paper
newt's Commander I know what you're
thinking use Commander isn't he from the
Fantastic Beast films he isn't in Harry
Potter and if you thought that well
you'd only be sort of right sure enough
we don't see newt's Commander's face in
the Harry Potter films but that
certainly doesn't mean that he's absent
from the Harry Potter Universe Newt is a
famous magic zoologist and the author A
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
An approved book at Hogwarts school so
you can bet that he's kicking around
somewhere to add to this there's
actually a newt Easter egg in the Harry
Potter films where he appears on the
Marauders map if you want to know the
explanation for his presence there well
you're going to have to watch my video
on it anyway despite what some sources
may say Newt was very much alive after
the Deathly Hallows book film timeline
had ended by the time the 1990s rolled
around Newt was pseudo-retired and
living in Dorset with Tina and their
three pet nasals hoppy Milly and Mauler
I say pseudo retired because Newt a
workaholic continued several projects
including studying fire slugs and
authoring a book entitled a children's
anthology of monsters Newt eventually
went on to become a great grandfather
when his grandson Rolf married Luna
Lovegood and had two children Larkin and
Lysander
Cho Chang Cho Chang was a Half-Blood
witch born in 1978 who attended Hogwarts
from 1990 to 1997 where she was sorted
into Ravenclaw House Joe was polite well
liked and easy to get along with and Cho
is well known for her relationships with
several male figures in the series
including Cedric Diggory and even Harry
Potter himself
after the death of Cedric Cho was never
quite the same and as it turns out she
ended up marrying a muggle upon
graduation perhaps this was just her way
of Escaping The Madness of The Wizarding
World particularly after a lethal
Wizarding War there are some theories
circling around the internet The Cho
actually ended up marrying Dudley
dursley of all people but if you want to
learn more about that whole situation
then watch my video on it
Andromeda Tonks Andromeda Tonks born
Andromeda black of the House of black
was an English witch that married
muggleborn Ted Tonks together her and
Ted had a daughter nymphadora who we
know as a respected Aura and a member of
the Order of the Phoenix
Andromeda despite being a member of the
House of black was not an evil witch so
it should come as no surprise that she
was disowned by her family a group of
pure blood supremacists after she
married a muggleborn Andromeda was also
a good example of a southern student
that wasn't and didn't turn bad
tragically many of andromeda's family
members died during the events of the
Deathly Hallows including her husband
Ted and her daughter nymphadora with
nymphadora leaving behind a son Teddy
who she had with her husband Remus
Lupine Andromeda was left to take care
of him
Moaning Myrtle Myrtle Warren AKA Moaning
Myrtle was a muggle-born wedge born in
either 1928 or 1929. Myrtle attended
Hogwarts from 1940 to 1943. some of the
same years as Voldemort and was
eventually killed in 1943 by Southern's
basilisk under Tom Riddle's orders after
the incident she became a ghost who
haunted the second floor girls bathroom
despite being well dead Myrtle became
quite a prominent character in the Harry
Potter series known for her strange
interactions with Harry the last time
Harry saw Myrtle however was when she
was ordered to leave the bathroom by
Severus Snape though there was nothing
in Harry Potter Canon indicating what
happened to Myrtle it's worth mentioning
that she does appear in the cursed child
where she can be found still haunting
the bathroom
xenophilius Lovegood xenophilius was the
husband of late Pandora Lovegood and
father to Fan Favorite Luna Lovegood
xenophilius was also notably the creator
of the quibbler magazine
during the second Wizarding War Luna was
captured by the Death Eaters which
prompted A desperate xenophilius to
alert Death Eaters during a visit from
Harry Potter in the hopes that they
would release Luna after Henry Ron and
Hermione escaped his home xenophilius
was promptly arrested and sent to
Azkaban he was finally released after
Voldemort's defeat on the 2nd of may
1998. not much is known of what happened
to xenophilius after that but it's
likely that he continued on with the
quibbler and occasionally took care of
his grandsons
Katie Bell Katie Bell was a British
half-bud witch born in the year 1979.
she was a member of Gryffindor House and
represented the house on the Quidditch
pitch taking on the role of Chaser she
was a year above Harry and we see her
name mentioned here and there throughout
the franchise however her character was
never really brought to the Forefront of
our attention until the halfberg Prince
When while on a trip to hogsmead Katie
suffered a brutal attack from an
unidentified curse because it took
Katie's six months to recover she ended
up returning to Hogwarts in 1997 to 1998
to repeat her seventh year Katie along
with others fought valiantly in the
Battle of Hogwarts and was seen sitting
after the battle with Joe Padma and
Leanne no one knows what happened to
Katie after that
Bane Bane was a centaur who lived in the
Forbidden Forest Central Colony along
with Firenze though the centaurs did not
initially join the Battle of Hogwarts
they were later shamed into it after
Hagrid called Bane a coward not much is
known of what happened to Bane but we do
know he survived the battle Bane also
appears in the cursed child act 2 scene
5 when Harry Potter is looking for his
son Albus
Winky Winky was a fan favorite character
that was omitted from the films entirely
a female house elf that serve the Crouch
family for many years and later worked
at Hogwarts at one stage in Winky's life
she fell into a depression after she
felt that she had failed to service
Barty Crouch which resulted in a
drinking problem her addiction to
butterbeer was a problem for many years
led by creature winky did end up helping
to fight against the Death Eaters during
the Battle of Hogwarts alongside other
house elves after the war had ended
winky continued to work at Hogwarts and
fortunately ended up beating her
butterbeer addiction
poppy pum free poppy Pomfrey also known
as Madame Pomfrey was the matron at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry responsible for taking care of
the students and staff of the school
however as it turns out Pomfrey wasn't
just responsible for healing people as
she fought valiantly alongside her
students and co-workers in the Battle of
Hogwarts taking down at least one Death
Eater herself after the battle we can
only assume that Madame Pomfrey returned
to her regular post tending to the
various medical maladies that came
through the doors of the Hogwarts
Hospital Wing if you want to go by
cursed child Cannon then we do actually
know for certain that she was still
working at the school in 2020
mandungus Fletcher mandungus Fletcher
was a half-bud wizard with a rich
history of criminal activity there
aren't many positive ways to describe
mandungus as a person as throughout the
story he always seemed to be getting
into trouble and getting on people's bad
sides mandungus is even partly
responsible for the death of Moody as he
abandoned him during the battle of the
seven Potters he also shamelessly raids
number 12 grimald Place looting and
selling all of the valuables that lay
within after being confronted by Harry
for this he disapparated and went into
hiding that is until he was imprisoned
in Azkaban for impersonating an
inferious it's unlikely that mandungas
played any part in the Battle of
Hogwarts and it's likely that he simply
returned to his life as a questionable
and unauthorized dealer of magical
artifacts
Rolanda Hooch Rolanda or Madame Hooch is
a British witch was speculated to been
born some time before the year 1918.
there isn't that much information
available on her and she doesn't appear
in the books or films very much however
she is very important in that she is the
one responsible for teaching the
students their foundational knowledge of
flying broomsticks not only that but
Madame Hooch is a quidditch referee an
aerial sport really a whole world
revolves around flying which is why it
shouldn't surprise you that after the
war had ended Madame Hooch simply
returned to her post at Hogwarts where
she continued to teach flying and
referee quidditch for many years to come
is a British pure blood wizard born in
either 1880 or 1881. notably Doge was a
close friend of Dumbledore their
friendship blossoming during their
Schoolboy years
while at Hogwarts Doge came down with a
bad case of dragon pox causing everyone
to avoid him except of course for
Dumbledore elphius was an active member
of the Order of the Phoenix in both Wars
and the ministry of magic jurist poison
peace specialist Rita Skeeter would
often refer to Doge as dimwitted however
that's likely only due to his lack of
cooperation during the writing of
Skeeter's magnum opus the life and lies
of Albus Dumbledore in fact Doge a
special advisor to the wizard gamut was
quite the opposite of dimwitted and
lived out the rest of his days serving
the British Ministry for magic arguing
with great aunt Muriel and missing his
dear friend Alba stumbledore
creature creature was a male house elf
born in an unknown year who loyally
served at the house of black for the
majority of his life that is until he
was left with Harry Potter after the
death of Sirius
before this however creature was known
to be fiercely loyal to sirius brother
regulus who he shared a special bond
with after the death of regulus creature
was a bit lost never learning to
properly respect his new master serious
however creature did eventually come to
respect Harry who treated him extremely
well during the Battle of Hogwarts
creature led the house elves Into The
Fray against Lord Voldemort and his
followers creature ended up Surviving
the battle and from that point entered
into full-time service of the Potter
family in 2017 JK Rowling revealed the
creature did eventually die at the
tender age of 666 where he was at that
time as anyone's guess
Victor Crum Victor Crum is a Bulgarian
wizard born in 1976 perhaps best known
for competing against Harry Fleur and
Cedric in the Triwizard Tournament
representing his school durmstrang
Crum was an exceptionally gifted
quidditch player and was the Seeker for
the Bulgarian national Quidditch team at
the tender age of 18. in 1994 he played
in the final of the Quidditch World camp
and he was still just a student and Krum
continued to play Quidditch for many
years before his eventual retirement
following the Bulgarian team's defeat in
the 2002 World Cup final however this
retirement didn't last long as Krum came
out of retirement to compete in the 2014
World Camp famously the Bulgarian team
won that Year's Camp beating out Brazil
in the finals cram retired a true a
quidditch Legend
John dulish John dulish is a British
pure blood Wizard and Ministry of magic
employee who served the institution as
an aura for most of his career dawlish
worked directly underneath Cornelius
fudge accompanying him on various
assignments
dawlish would also later work for
ministers Rufus scrimger and Pious
thickness dawlish felt quite a few
assignments towards the end of the
second Wizarding War the most likely
reason being that he repeatedly faced
far superior opponents Dumbledore
unfamiliar situations Hagrid being a
half Giant and continual placement under
the confundus charm not much is known of
what happened to dawlish following the
war but we do know that he survived and
that he continued to act not quite right
for some time after most likely due to
his repeated subjection to the confundus
charm it's unlikely that dawlish was
charged as a sympathizer of Voldemort
and it's entirely probable that due to
his brain damage he ended up in Saint
mungo's
Blaze zabini Blaze sabini was a pure
blood wizard that attended Hogwarts
around the same time as Harry Potter he
was a member of Southern house and was
on good terms with Draco Malfoy and his
gang Blaze was a quiet boy that mostly
kept to himself but on occasion would
Express his extreme prejudice towards
Muggles muggleborns and blood traitors
no one knows exactly what happened to
blaze post-war but we do know that he
probably survived as most southern
students sat the battle out given that
Blaze was skilled in potion making
progressing to the Newt level in the
subject it's entirely possible that he
pursued a career in potions
Mrs fig Mrs fig AKA Arabella Doreen fig
was a Squibb that lived near Harry
Potter's childhood home on Private Drive
the darzi residents given that she lived
down the street from Harry she would
commonly babysit him simultaneously
helping to keep an eye on him for
helpless Dumbledore though Mrs fig did
whatever she could to help the order and
good guys as a squib it's unlikely that
she participated in the Battle of
Hogwarts it wouldn't have been safe for
her there given her affinity for furry
feline companions I like to imagine that
Mrs fig lived out the rest of her days
crossbreeding and trading part needle
cats
Marcus Flint Marcus Flint was a pure
blood wizard born in 1976 whose family
name appeared on the sacred 28 a list of
28 pure blood Wizarding families he
attended Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry from 1987 to 1994 and
notably served as captain of the
Southern Quidditch team from at least
1991 to 1994. Flint was one of Harry's
quidditch Rivals no one knows what
happened to Marcus Flint but given his
affinity for the mockery of others and
inability to play nice I doubt he got
far there's always the possibility he
became a professional quidditch player
but I personally don't think that any
teams would have welcomed him on board
Ernie MacMillan
Ernie MacMillan was a purebred wizard
who attended Hogwarts during the same
years as Harry Potter notably
Ernie was the one who suspected that
Harry Potter was the heir of Slytherin
during the opening of the Chamber of
Secrets in his second year that is until
Hermione was petrified and Ernie changed
his mind later apologizing to Harry
Ernie survived the battle of Hogwarts
but not much is known of his later life
I like to imagine that he stayed in
touch with his good friends Hannah
Abbott and Justin Finch fletchley which
would also put him in Neville's Social
Circle given that Hannah was married to
Neville
Crookshanks Crookshanks was Hermione's
half needle pet cat that she purchased
from magical Menagerie in 1993.
Crookshanks was a particularly
intelligent cat helping to expose Peter
Pettigrew as scabbers though Crookshanks
is very cute and highly intelligent it's
unlikely that he would have been much
help during the final battle of the war
so instead he stayed at the home of the
Weasleys the borough waiting things out
until everything had settled down he was
later reunited with Hermione given that
Crookshanks was just a cat in a pet
store that apparently nobody wanted he
really did make quite an impact on the
story Angelina Johnson Angelina Johnson
was a witch born in 1977. she played a
reasonably active role in the series
becoming a member of Dumbledore's Army
and also captaining the Gryffindor
Quidditch team in her seventh year which
was also Harry's fifth year like I
mentioned much earlier in the video
Angelina went on to marry George Weasley
with whom she had children the weird bit
about it is that Angelina was Fred's ex
but what are you gonna do to make things
a bit more weird one of their children
was called Fred fret II and their
daughter was named Roxanne Fang Fang is
a lovable but timid borehand that we
know is one of Hagrid's closest
companions in the Harry Potter series he
is often seen following Hagrid around
and is known for his loyalty and gentle
temperament after the events of the last
book it is unclear what happened to Fang
however it is likely that he simply
continued to live at Hogwarts and spend
his days with Hagrid with Hagrid by his
side it's likely that Fang lived out the
rest of his days exploring the Forbidden
Forest and napping in Hagrid's Hut
Millicent bolstered another contemporary
of Harry's was a Half-Blood wedge you
may remember Millicent as the Slytherin
student who Hermione tried to
impersonate using polyju's potion in the
Chamber of Secrets unfortunately for
Hermione it was Millicent's cat hair
that she used in the potion transforming
her partially into a cat during the
Battle of Hogwarts it's likely that
Millicent fled the castle rather than
choose to fight against Voldemort in the
Death Eaters given that Millicent had no
particularly good qualities and wasn't
particularly intelligent it's hard to
imagine her amounting to much I expect
that she ended up with a low level job
at the ministry of magic mafalda hopkirk
Madam mafolder hopkirk was a British
witch and an assistant in the improper
use of magic office at the ministry of
magic who notably sends Harry letters on
two occasions once in the Chamber of
Secrets and once in the Order of the
Phoenix informing him of his improper
use of magic outside of school Irma
Pence Irma is a strict librarian at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry after the events of the last
book it's possible that Irma continued
on as the school's librarian ensuring
that students had access to the
knowledge they needed to succeed in
their studies it's likely that Irma
worked until retirement constantly
surrounded by the books she loved so
much Ludo bagman Ludo is a former
professional quidditch player and the
head of the Department of magical games
and sports after the events of the last
book Ludo likely went into hiding to
avoid punishment for his involvement in
illegal gambling it's possible that he
was eventually caught and brought to
Justice or that he continued to live on
the Run always looking over his shoulder
Justin Finch fletchley Justin is a
muggle-born student at Hogwarts who
assorted into Hufflepuff after the
events of the last book Justin likely
returned to his family and continued his
studies at Hogwarts it's possible they
went on to have successful career in The
Wizarding World using its intelligence
and determination to make a difference
Amos diggery Amos is the father of
Cedric degree the Hogwarts student who
was killed by Lord Voldemort during the
trium was a tournament or more
accurately killed by Peter Pettigrew
after the events of the last book Amos
likely struggled to cope the loss of his
son and eventually found peace with the
help of his family and friends it's
possible that he became an advocate for
those who lost loved ones in the war
working to ensure that their sacrifices
were never forgotten Amos does have a
role in The Cursed child story but I'm
not going to get into that peeves peeves
is a poltergeist as mischief and Mayhem
and Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry after the events of the last
book it's unclear what happened to
peeves however it's possible that he
continued to cause trouble at Hogwarts
delighting in the chaos and confusion he
could create alternatively he may have
simply disappeared content to let the
world move on without him although this
seems unlikely Dennis creepy Dennis is
the younger brother of Colin creevy a
Hogwarts student who was killed during
the Battle of Hogwarts after the events
of the last book Dennis likely returned
to Hogwarts to finish his studies after
which he may have pursued photography
just like his brother Daphne Greengrass
Daphne is a Slytherin student at
Hogwarts who is known for her beauty and
Poise after the events of the last book
it's unclear what happened to Daphne her
sister on the other hand ended up
marrying Draco Malfoy it's possible that
she went on to have a successful career
in The Wizarding World using her
intelligence and cunning to get ahead
Susan bones Susan is a Hufflepuff
student at Hogwarts who was a member of
Dumbledore's Army after the events of
the last book Susan likely returned to
Hogwarts to finish her studies and
became a respected member of The
Wizarding Community it's possible that
she went on to become an aura or other
type of law enforcement officer using
her bravery and intellect to keep the
Wizarding World safe Lee Jordan Lee is a
former Gryffindor student at Hogwarts
who is a commentator for The Wizarding
radio station potterwood much after the
events of the last book Lee likely
continues his career as a radio
commentator and remained a close friend
of Harry's it's possible that he went on
to become a journalist or other type of
media personality using his wit and
charm to entertain and inform the
Wizarding World Stan Chan Pike Stan is a
British wizard that worked as a
conductor on the Night Bus later joining
the Death Eaters after being placed
under the imperius curse after the event
of the last book Stan likely avoided
punishment for his involvement the Death
Eaters and went into hiding it's
possible that he eventually resurfaced
and tried to make amends for his past
mistakes all that he continued to live a
life of secrecy and isolation Penelope
Clearwater Penelope is a former
Ravenclaw student at Hogwarts who is
romantically involved with Percy Weasley
after the events of the last book it's
unclear what happened to Penelope but we
do know that she didn't end up with
Percy Alicia spinett Alicia is a former
Gryffindor student at Hogwarts as a
member of the Gryffindor Quidditch
after the events of the last book it's
unclear what happened to Alicia it's
possible that she continued to play
Quidditch professionally using her skill
and determination to become one of the
best players in the world alternatively
she may have left the world of quidditch
behind and pursued a different career
Teddy Lupine Teddy is the son of Remus
Lupine and infidora tongs and their
metamorph makers like his mother after
the events of the last book Teddy went
on to live with his grandmother but he
also spent a considerable amount of time
with his Godfather Harry it's possible
that he went on to become an aura or
other type of law enforcement officer
following in the footsteps of his
parents at his grandfather alternatively
he may have pursued a career in a
different field using his unique
abilities to make a difference in The
Wizarding World crab and Goyle Vincent
crab and Gregory Goyle are two
slytherins known for their Fierce
loyalty to Draco Malfoy often acting as
his henchman grab is a large and
intimidating young man with a short
temper while Goyle is quiet and reserved
but equally dangerous both are
physically strong and are often called
upon to perform physical tasks despite
their tough exteriors they can be easily
manipulated by those who know how to
push their buttons however the fates of
these two is a bit confusing you see
depending on what you know these
characters from book first film a
different one was killed off in the book
crab dies and Goyle lives whereas in the
film Goyle dies actor Jamie whalet
played Vincent Crabb in the first six
movies but after taking part in the
London riots in 2011 he was sent to
prison for two years because of this he
was unable to take part in the Deathly
Hallows movies which led to the decision
to kill Goyle instead if kraba died in
the book it's possible that Gregory
would have been taken to trial for his
involvement with the Death Eaters
alternatively he may have gone into
hiding trying to avoid punishment for
his crimes Augusta Longbottom Augusta is
the grandmother of Neville Longbottom
and a fierce supporter of the Order of
the Phoenix
after the events of the last book
Augusta likely continued to support the
Wizarding community and help those who
had been affected by the war it's
possible that she became a mentor to
other young witches and wizards passing
on her knowledge and experience to the
Next Generation Mary Esther Edgecombe
Marietta is a former student at Hogwarts
who betrayed Dumbledore's Army to
Umbridge after the events of the last
book it's unknown what happened to her
it's possible that she changed her tune
and tried to make amends for her past
mistakes Albert runcorn Albert is a
minister of magic employee who was
impersonated by Harry Potter using the
polyju's potion after the event of the
last book it's unclear what happened to
Albert it's possible that he was able to
clear his name and continue working at
the ministry or that he was fired for
his involvement with the Darth eaters
Reginald catamol Reginald is a Ministry
of magic employee who was impersonated
by Ron Weasley using the Polyjuice
Potion after the event of the last book
it's unclear what happened to Reginald
it's possible that he was able to clear
his name and continue working in the
ministry or that he was fired for his
involvement with the Death Eaters
Zechariah Smith Zacharias is a former
student at Hogwarts who was a member of
Dumbledore's Army after the events of
the last book it's unclear what happened
to Zacharias it's possible that he went
on to have a successful career in The
Wizarding World using his intelligence
and determination to make a difference
alternatively he may have struggled to
find his place in a world that had been
torn apart by War Buckbeak Buckbeak is a
hippogriff who was rescued by Harry
Potter in the third book after the
events of the last book Buckbeak likely
continued to live at Hogwarts and be
cared for by Hagrid forks forks is the
Beloved Phoenix of Albus Dumbledore and
a powerful magical creature after
Dumbledore's death Fox flees Hogwarts as
he laid there he became aware suddenly
the grounds were silent Fox had stopped
singing and he knew without knowing how
he knew it that the Phoenix had gone had
left Hogwarts for good just as
Dumbledore had left the school had left
the world had left Harry Pious thickness
Pious thickness was a high-ranking
Ministry of magic official who was
placed under the imperious curse by Lord
Voldemort after the events of the last
book it's likely that Pious was put on
trial for his involvement with the Death
Eaters it's possible that he was able to
clear His Name by proving that he was
under the imperious curse or that he was
punished for his crimes Antonin dalahov
Antonin is a Death Eater who fought in
the side of Lord Voldemort during the
second Wizarding war after the event of
the last book it's likely that Antonin
was captured and put on trial for his
crimes it's possible that he was
sentenced to life in Azkaban or that he
was given the Dementors kiss and had his
soul sucked out it's also possible that
he was killed by Flitwick Walden McNair
Walden is a Ministry of magic employee
who specializes in the capture and
control of magical creatures after the
events of the last book it's unclear
what happened to Walden it's possible
that he was able to clear his name and
continue working in the ministry all
that he was fired for his involvement
with the Death Eaters the latter seems
more likely thorphineral thorfin is a
Death Eater who fought on the side of
Lord Voldemort during the second
Wizarding war after the events of the
last book it's likely that thorfin was
captured and put on trial for his crimes
eventually either sentenced to life in
Azkaban or given the Dementors kiss
corbinaxley Corbin is a high-ranking
Death Eater who is placed in charge of
the Department of magical law
enforcement during Voldemort's Reign
after the events of the last book is
likely that Corbin was captured and put
on trial for his crimes it's possible
that he was able to escape punishment by
claiming that he was under the Imperials
cause or that he was held accountable
for his actions and punished accordingly
Snape Legacy only Snape is a former
Hogwarts professor and a member of the
Order of the Phoenix who sacrificed his
life to help defeat Lord Voldemort after
the event of the last bug Snape was
remembered as a hero who worked
tirelessly to protect and save those he
cared about it's possible that his
legacy continued to inspire others to
fight for what was right even in the
face of overwhelming odds Amicus Cairo
when Lord Voldemort led the coup against
the ministry of magic he used his
Newfound power to install his agents in
positions of power Across The Wizarding
World one of these agents was Amicus
Cairo a prominent dark wizard who had
once fought alongside the dark lord
during the first Wizarding war in the
late 70s after which Amicus rejoined the
Death Eaters in their reign of terror
across Britain eventually culminating in
Cara's appointment as professor of
defense against the dark arts at
Hogwarts but in the aftermath of the
final battle there when Voldemort was
killed by Harry Potter where did karob
end up conventional wisdom would point
to Azkaban just like the Death Eaters
from the first Wizarding War the dark
Wizards from his conflict were being
sent back to that Wizarding prison to
serve life sentences
electocarrow electocarrow was amicus's
sister and shared a similar fate just
like her brother Electro was one of the
most important Death Eaters during
Voldemort's campaigns in the second
Wizarding War as the dark lord slowly
eroded away the ministry of Magic's
legal Powers electo carried out missions
to keep the rest of the British
Wizarding World too afraid to fight back
eventually she earned herself a
professorship at Hogwarts under the
direction of its new Headmaster Severus
Snape but after a tumultuous career
there Electro's tenure ended with the
Battle of Hogwarts Augustus Rookwood
Augustus Rookwood was one of Voldemort's
most formidable allies and by the time
of the second Wizarding War one of his
oldest Rookwood served a unique role
within the rank of the Death Eaters he
was a mold within the ministry of magic
of course for Voldemort to succeed in
his campaigns against his fellow Wizards
he needed to lure many influential
Ministry workers to his cause during the
Battle of Hogwarts Augustus met his
match when he took on Albus Dumbledore's
younger brother aberforth
Augustus was stunned in the
confrontation and just like the Cairo
siblings his story ends there
most assumed he died or was quickly
ferried off to Azkaban fenrir greyback
fenrir greybach might seem like a
run-of-the-mill Death Eater but he
actually wasn't he worked closely with
Voldemort and his dark wizards but
fenria actually wasn't officially part
of the crew instead the werewolf Allied
himself with Voldemort because they
shared a common goal overthrowing the
existing power structure in the
Wizarding World fenrir just like Tom
Riddle had a problem with wizards they
held a prejudice against werewolves and
treated those infected with lycanthropy
as a type of vermin that terrorized
their communities fenrir was not only
offended by that ideology but enraged
and he made it his personal goal to
infect as many Wizards with lycanthropy
as possible so that he could create an
army large enough to undo the ministry
of magic but that all came to a halt
during the Battle of Hogwarts there Ron
Weasley and Neville Longbottom beat
fenrir and in the aftermath it's likely
that the werewolf was bound in magical
chains and escorted into a cell in
Azkaban if he wasn't killed in the
battle and that's it for this video
hopefully that gives you a little bit
more information on the lives of these
characters beyond the books if I missed
anyone or if I got anything wrong be
sure to comment down below happy to
answer follow-up questions down there as
well until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
[Music]
thank you